porque estamos viendo una reacción poco
común podemos decir en el mundo del
deporte unido así que esta vez sí contra
rusia para sancionarla por esta invasión
contra ucrania para ello vamos a
conectar con el periodista argentino
deportivo gonzalo bonadeo que nos
acompaña desde la ciudad de buenos aires
gonzalo muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo american hay una
respuesta contundente contra el deporte
ruso en esta ocasión ni siquiera cuando
se destapó el escándalo del paje de
estado hubo una reacción similar porque
esta vez es así
entiendo que para empezar el primer buen
día cómo le vas
entiendo que esto no es algo nuevo en
cuanto a la conducta de algunas
corporaciones en cuanto a trabajar al
respecto de deporte y política esto que
tantas veces se dice más bueno mezclar
deporte y política es algo de seguir
mezclando desde tiempos ancestrales por
portal peso específico tienen deporte en
la vida de cada uno de nosotros respecto
de esta decisión debo decir que es muy
difícil para mí y más allá de cuestionar
profundamente lo que es la invasión de
rusia ucrania y la agresión militar en
términos deportivos tanto la fifa como
el coi tienen antecedentes que me
permiten dudar de la fidelidad de estas
decisiones no son coherentes con cosas
del pasado eso es lo primero que se me
ocurre y precisamente de eso les quería
preguntar yo en la historia cuáles son
los antecedentes entonces que puedan
haber digamos hecho algo similar o no
hay absolutamente nada
hubo un boicot en 1980 a los juegos
olímpicos de moscú por la invasión
soviética a afganistán una nación tan
autónoma como ucrania en aquel momento y
sin embargo hubo algunos países incluido
argentina que no envió deportistas pero
gran bretaña australia italia españa
francia brasil no sé si méxico también
creo que no mandaron de sus delegaciones
con a regañadientes los políticos
haciendo campañas en contra pero los
atletas austria también envió sus
competidores a los juegos olímpico de
moscú por citar un ejemplo olímpico en
cuanto a los mundiales esto de evitar
los cruces habrá hay una decisión
ninguna decisión es perfecta en este
caso porque hay un agarre por medio
entonces siempre es ingrato porque si
vamos a autorizar a los rusos con todo
derecho no crean ya no puede decidir no
competir contra ellos pero recordamos
que en 1970 la única vez que jugó un
mundial de fútbol israel lo hizo
compitiendo en el grupo asiático donde
norcorea el norte decidió no jugar
justamente por boicot a israel y a
partir de ese momento de red pasó a
competir en las competencias europeas
tanto equipos de clubes como
seleccionado nacionales pese a ser
geográfica hacia esto es algo que no es
nuevo en aquel juego del 70 también
rhodesia parte de áfrica también
compitió en asia o sea es como que todo
el tiempo tratan de buscar un camino
para esquivar ciertas situaciones
profundas y conflictivas porque en
definitiva queda claro que los
deportistas en sí mismo no tienen la
responsabilidad de lo que hace putting
volviendo al tema que del quebrado usted
antes acerca de que no hay una fidelidad
dice usted en la digestión del coi de la
fifa venimos justamente a ver unos
juegos olímpicos de invierno en china en
medio de ver una gran acumulación de
denuncias por violación de derechos
humanos en ese país
bueno pero y más que eso no solamente
hay reclamos en su momento en sobre
beijing y la conducta de xi jinping
respecto de las minorías musulmanas sino
que putin era la misma persona en 2014
cuando se hicieron el juegos olímpicos
de sochi o en la misma persona del 2018
cuando la fifa hizo el mundial en rusia
mundial en el cual estuve y que veías
una moscú espléndida sant petersburgo
espléndido y sin embargo era la misma
gente o sea la única diferencia que no
es menor era que no había una acción
militar directa pero en definitiva en
términos de conducta bueno a ver ya
había pasado lo de osetia
los conflictos en chechenia o sea no es
un tema nuevo también yo quería entonces
preguntarle porque los deportistas son
los que terminan pagando los platos
rotos como usted lo estaba diciendo de
alguna manera esto realmente puede ser
una presión a vladimir putin para que de
alguna manera
impida la guerra o sea en el terreno
real
que hacen que afecta esto a vladimir
putin bueno hay un ejemplo que quizás
pueda mirarse desde un costado que es el
de sudáfrica y nelson mandela la
hegemonía blanca en sudáfrica se
expresaba en el deporte atrás de los
springboks su seleccionado de rugby y
los primos estaban prohibidos cuando
mándela es liberado cuando empieza el
cambio de poder en sudáfrica y se
termina siendo mundial de radio el 95 o
sea el deporte el run que en ese caso
fue decisivo para la revolución que armó
nelson mandela en principios de la
cárcel y después ya en libertad después
es
realmente ingrato recién hablaba del
problema que tenía rusia con la agencia
mundial antidopaje y con el doping de
estado bueno si hacemos cifras de
deportistas dopados no han sido menos
los deportistas sobre todo atletas
velocistas norteamericanos que han
tenido casos de doping en este tiempo la
diferencia sustancial es que no sólo
considera doping sistemático entonces no
hay una sanción integrada del deporte y
como si se hizo con los rusos
particularmente hablando de este tema de
sancionar a un solo deportista estamos
viendo un escenario muy peculiar en el
tenis desde ayer lunes un nuevo número
uno del mundo es un tenista ruso de mis
bienes primera vez en muchos años que no
es uno del denominado big ford y le
están pidiendo la ite efe de la
federación internacional de tenis que
excluye a los tenistas rusos y
particularmente podríamos ver entonces
un caso en donde un chico de la nueva
generación que le ha costado mucho
llegar al número uno del tenis que se
quede sin jugar y defender es el nuevo
número 1 del tenis que acaba de ganar
bueno además se trata del país ganador
de la última copa davis está el roble
beta kasyanov es una mega potencia en
este tiempo rusia carache es un es un
país con una larga tradición tenística
en definitiva
yo entiendo que el deporte se mezcla con
la política tanto como la política con
el deporte es son un romance muy
particular que es muy difícil de dividir
insisto desde tiempos muy lejanos de
nuestra de nuestra propia existencia
ahora
dijo el comité olímpico que no es no hay
solución perfecta en este caso te decía
recién bueno me parece que habrá que
sostener la idea de ahí está roble
justamente diciendo no word no no no no
queremos guerra bueno quizás que
compitan sin himnos sin bandera como
pase los juegos olímpicos que son
atletas neutrales a patrias ya civiles a
enea pero me parece que sí es un factor
de presión para que putin a través de la
presión desde la opinión pública a flo
que con esta medida respecto de la
invasión y la guerra sobre ucrania está
perfecta está muy bien debería ser una
medida momentánea que es lo que se está
decidiendo en este tiempo si van más
allá me parece estarían cometiendo una
gran injusticia respecto de gente
probablemente no está de acuerdo con lo
que sheput y es más a ver debo decir
algo respecto de la fifa nosotros
tuvimos un mundial en plena dictadura en
la república argentina había mucha gente
en contra de lo que fue la dictadura se
supo muy bien las atrocidades que
cometieron los dictadores en aquel
momento que fueron socios de la fifa del
mundial 78 y no hubo ninguna medida en
contra de argentina claro gonzález
juanan y también hemos visto las
reacciones de los deportistas que están
en contra de todo esto y el apoya la
ucrania a los no juan estamos llegando a
la conclusión de que esto no es nuevo ha
habido sanciones pero entonces porque
esta vez la fifa actúa así tiene algo
que ver cree usted con que hay este año
mundial en qatar un país también sobre
que hay en el que hay muchas críticas
bueno para empezar la fifa tiene unos
antecedentes complicados no casualmente
estuvo buscando caminos alternativos en
los últimos mundiales pasamos de
mundiales en italia mundiales en
alemania a mundiales en brasil y
naturalmente una gran historia deportiva
pero también mundiales en sudáfrica que
era la primera del campo mundial o la
segunda virtual mundial lo de rusia
tampoco era saber no nos olvidemos que
rusia y qatar le ganan la elección en la
fifa a eeuu y gran bretaña
decisiones harto polémicas que además
derivaron el famoso fifa light de alguna
manera es un tema muy complejo y
entiendo que la fifa que se siente muy
poderosa porque nos da el gran producto
mayoritario en el mundo del deporte que
es el fútbol tiene conflictos internos
serios y en este momento me parece a mí
es buena prensa manifestarse bien en
contra de lo que es la acción de putin
para tapar un poco también entonces es
todo este escándalo que ha habido como
también lo lo quería decir juegan en
torno a este mundial que se va a jugar
en qatar qatar 2022 también gonzalo le
quiero decir que si estamos condenados
para siempre de que la política siempre
esté involucrada con el deporte cuando
no tienen absolutamente nada que ver y
también por todos los casos de
corrupción que se viene en el deporte
precisamente por esto por la por la
política a gonzalo es inevitable mirar
el año 36 estos organismos harto
conocida en los juegos olímpicos fueron
en berlín en el berlín de hitler en ese
momento y una delegación norteamericana
que bajó a unos sus velocistas martí
glickman por ser de origen judío bajo el
concepto de ella bastante le dimos con
jesse owens un negro ganando en alemania
si un judío le gané a hitler y la
persona que tomó la decisión era fue 36
años después presidente del comité
olímpico avery brundage y él como
presidente del coi fue el mismo que
anunció la continua de los juegos de
múnich en medio de la masacre de atletas
israelíes o sea eso es un romance
histórico indivisible para mi entender
porque muchos de los grandes talentos
que nosotros vemos se desarrollan a
través de aporte de los estados siguen
muchísimos países incluido en argentina
a partir de eso los políticos quieren la
foto quieren estar cerca quiere estar
vinculados y quieren tomar decisiones
gracias gonzalo por haber estado con
nosotros en directo a américa muchísimas
gracias por ese tiempo y este análisis
sobre esas sanciones que continúan raúl